Rotten Tomatoes can be a vital resource
for many cinephiles but as useful as the
site's tomato meter can be it isn't
exactly perfect over the years many
genuinely fantastic films have been hit
by terrible rotten tomato scores here
are a few of the very best it isn't hard
to see why underworld wasn't a huge hit
with critics
it's a shamelessly pokey ode to vampires
werewolves and billowing black leather
characters have names like Kraven and
Selene dual wield all their weapons and
regularly say stuff like this
differences will be set aside
allegiances will be made and soon I will
become the hunted reviewers found a
goofy overly serious and kind of dumb to
boot not long removed from the period in
which it was released however underworld
has revealed itself as a heck of a lot
of fun Kate Beckinsale is wonderfully
steely as Selene a vampiric assassin
known as a death dealer driven by a
centuries-old grudge the supporting cast
is also stacked with talent Bill Nighy
Martin Sheen and urban later give their
all as a wide variety of creatures going
bump in the night underworld has even
become a franchise since the first films
2003 debut comprising five films comic
books video games and an animated
feature these days it's still exactly as
silly and violence as you might imagine
and that's why it's remembered so fondly
by so many fans 2000s pitch black is an
impressive piece of sci-fi horror that
gave the world Richard B Riddick what
have been Diesel's first major roles it
did quite well on a relatively low
budget of twenty three million dollars
earning a fifty three million dollar
gross and a solid fan base to go with it
diesel is a particular highlight to the
film as Riddick a notorious criminal was
sci-fi super vision he plays a
charismatic antihero whose fighting
skills are matched only by his ironclad
determination pitchblack turned to
prophet diesel wowed audiences and thus
a sequel was insured 2004 is The
Chronicles of Riddick Chronicles budget
grew by leaps and bounds ultimately
landing out a hundred and five million
dollars a far cry from pitch blacks
modest spending but this turned out to
be a grave mistake
critics savaged the film as a limp
disappointments being all the more
lackluster following pitch-black
surprising success in the end chronicles
brought in just a hundred and fifteen
million dollars at the box office how
then did the series garner a third
installment in 2013
Hritik direct-to-dvd animated feature
and a couple of video game tie-ins in
shorts is because chronicles is wildly
misunderstood
unlike pitch black the focus here is
entirely on Riddick who explores the
setting that leans far more toward
science fiction than horror it's
sweeping strange and an enormous amount
of fun once you take it on its own
merits plus it was on this set that Vin
Diesel taught Judi Dench how to play
Dungeons & Dragons and that just
straight up rules Godzilla king of the
monsters dismal critical reception isn't
much of a mystery since it's not exactly
a film that's much interested in
conventional storytelling if you want to
care about characters with nuanced
struggles and conflicting choices this
isn't the movie for you if on the other
hand you want to see Godzilla Mothra
Rodin King Ghidorah and about 300 other
classic kaiju Duke it out across the
planet then you've come to the right
place this is the big-budget Godzilla
movie you've always wanted to see and
it's got all the wanton destruction you
could ever hope for there are plenty of
strong actors working to keep that shaky
plot together Ken Watanabe Milly Bobby
Brown and Bradley Whitford are all here
doing their best with a threadbare plot
but be honest you've come to Godzilla
for Godzilla not Godzilla's human pals
and king of the monsters more than
delivers on that front it's hard to
believe that hocus-pocus got trashed so
badly by critics considering how the
loved' it has become in the years since
its release part of that is the
nostalgia factor of course a lot of
people who champion hocus pocus today
probably watched it as kids and have
fond memories of it as a result too many
hocus-pocus is more of a stroll down
memory lane than an opportunity for
serious film criticism but hocus-pocus
fever isn't all nostalgia it's a
genuinely delightful movie and a great
showcase for its trio of powerhouse
actresses honestly the main reason the
movie did so poorly among critics is
probably bad timing hocus pocus was
released in July 1993 which is just
about the worst time of year to release
a movie like this a family-friendly
flake with a great cast and gentle
thrills could have cleaned up around
Halloween but instead it had to compete
with Jurassic Park hocus pocus just
didn't stand a chance once upon a time
the best you could hope for from a video
game adaptation was this
luckily Hollywood has finally figured
out the key to a successful adaptation
embracing the immersive worlds that
games create Warcraft is almost a great
example of that
it might not have the most interesting
characters or the best script but it
successfully brings the world of Azeroth
to life with impressive visuals and
sweeping cinematography critics however
were less than impressed Warcraft
brought in esteemed director Duncan
Jones to run the show and his talent and
appreciation of the source material
shows almost to a fault
most of the shortcoming to this film
come from its allegiance to the Warcraft
games and the movie makes the assumption
that the viewer is already pretty
familiar with Azeroth in its background
if you're in the know you're going to
find a ton to enjoy here if you don't
well then you might just agree with the
critics still for those already devoted
to the world of warcraft it's a fine
movie that's full to the brim with love
for the original games
Tokyo Drift is the ugly duckling of The
Fast and the Furious franchise it's
caught somewhere between the series is
grounded beginnings and the total
insanity that has powered more recent
entries what is unquestionable however
is how downright entertaining it is and
how it opened the franchise up to
international audiences who ensure the
success of later movies
Tokyo Drift is quite the departure from
the first two films there's neither a
Paul Walker and Norah Vin Diesel in
sight and the American muscle car scene
is left behind in favor of the neon
drenched glitz of Tokyo Tokyo Drift has
some of the coolest driving sequences in
the entire franchise however and marks a
distinct shift towards a more self-aware
tone ultimately that change was for the
past and it is allowed the Fast &
Furious franchise to become about
something more than the relatively niche
world of underground street racing there
is also a wonderful simplicity to Tokyo
Drift it's cool it's fast and it's not
too hung up on plot it aims to impress
and it does Phoebe Cates is too often
remembered as the eye candy of past
times at ridgemont high this is a real
shame however since she's a pretty
fantastic actress with some serious
range and there's no better
demonstration of her comedic chops then
drop dead Fred and all forgotten 1991
comedy sure the reviews are terrible but
that's only because critics walked in
with the wrong expectations and drop
dead Fred Cates plays Elizabeth a woman
dealing with the life in which
everything has gone wrong after her
marriage falls apart she moves back in
with her mother where she is reunited
her imaginary childhood friend drop dead
Fred played by the phenomenal Rik Mayall
Fred sets out to try to fix Elizabeth's
relationships and obviously makes things
even worse
what does that taste nice drop dead Fred
is an extremely dark comedy which threw
audiences for a loop when it was
released the studio was reportedly
unhappy with how dark it turned out and
tried to unload it after production
wrapped but it's also a biting and
surprisingly heartfelt story of
adulthood gone wrong as Tristar head
Mike meta boy put it at the time
it's a children's movie on drugs and
that's what bands love about it it's
tough to match legends pedigree this is
a Ridley Scott directed dark fantasy
starring a fresh-faced Tom Cruise as the
Robin Hood as Jack and Tim Curry decked
out and devilish makeup is the Lord of
Darkness legend might be eclipsed by
such contemporaries as labyrinth in the
Dark Crystal but it's still a remarkably
well-made film with some serious
darkness at its heart legend is
unquestionably beautiful to watch to
absolutely brimming with elegantly
realised world's costumes and creatures
then there's the cast Tom Cruise can be
polarizing now but few actors commanded
the screen quite like he did throughout
the 1980s Tim Curry is always a joy
especially when it gets to lap up the
scenery as a villain like the Lord of
Darkness Mia Sara best known as Sloane
Peterson from Ferris Bueller's Day Off
is wonderful as the impetuous
good-hearted princess Lily add in
legends intriguing the dark tone and
you've got the recipe for an absolute
classic of a movie 1999's The Boondock
Saints is certainly a product of its
time and it doesn't take long for you to
figure out what influences director Troy
Duffy was operating under and making
this movie Tarantino Guy Ritchie Martin
Scorsese and Hong Kong action movies
like hard-target they're all present in
Boondock Saints its lurid violent and
extreme just as the critic set but its
action scenes are genuinely innovative
and for all its blood and gore it's a
whole lot more fun than its given credit
for the boondock saints follows the
brothers Connor and Murphy McManus who
bat they're getting into a bar fight
target a bunch of mobsters they're soon
caught up in a series of violent
gunfights culminating in an assault on
the heart of the Russian mob it's
basically a less self-aware John wick
what really makes Boondock Saints work
though is its impressive cast Willem
Dafoe Sean Patrick Flanery
Norman Reedus and Billy Connolly all
featured here at their app
best so sure it's an indulgent violent
fantasy but that doesn't mean it's bad
belly is one of the most polarizing
films on Rotten Tomatoes with a whopping
72% difference between its critical and
audience score despite struggling to WoW
the critics however belly really is a
fascinating movie the plot isn't
anything to write home about but there's
so much style and talent involved that
it's pretty much impossible to ignore to
youth culture site complex has even
suggested that belly was so far ahead of
its time that it reshaped hip hop and
Hollywood in ways that are only now
becoming clear belly is the feature film
debut of legendary music video director
hype Williams and stars an absolute
wealth of rap hip-hop and R&B luminaries
it's a story about two men played by NAS
and DMX who try to free themselves from
their lives of crime after escaping from
the run-down Queens neighborhood of
their youth belly is a deeply felt
Odyssey of music compromise and life at
the bottom sure it's a little messy but
the sheer talent Verve and vision of the
film radiates from every prank many
critics saw belly's atmospheric
approaches hype Williams history and
music videos dragging him down modern
viewers know better that sleek style
forward approach is what makes belly
such an unforgettable watch
there aren't many big dumb action movies
better than the much-maligned bad boys -
it's Michael Bay it is Michael Bay ax
stand if you're not down with that
you'll hate it but that kind of sounds
like your thing then it'll be a dream
come true for this movie Will Smith and
Martin Lawrence come out in full force
from the first scene to the last ensure
Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus calls
bad boys to two and a half hours of
explosions and witless banter but that's
kind of the point isn't it there's a
plot in there of course Smith and
Lawrence return to play detectives Mike
Lowrey and Marcus Burnett who are tasked
with investigating Miami's ecstasy trade
they soon uncover a massive gang war for
control of the city's drug shipments and
their personal relationship is put at
stake when Lowrey starts crushing on
burnett sister but all of this is just
an excuse for bigger and better
explosions and that's 100% fine - not
every movie has to be the Godfather teen
horror doesn't tend to hit home with
critics it's a genre that prioritizes
pretty faces and high pot accounts over
skillful execution often employing
questionable logic to get it stars to
their bloody ends some of them deserved
better than the teen slasher label they
are assigned however and chief among
them is that critically derided fine
destination the first film in a five
film series final destination has a
killer premise once death has chosen you
there's no escape a high school student
named Alex boards a plane with several
classmates then foresees the plane
exploding killing everyone on board
after several people exit the plane
including Alex his premonition comes
true soon all those that got off the
plane start dying in a series of
elaborate ways and the survivors
determined that they did not cheat death
they only delayed it final destination
features some truly creative death
sequences making good on its
attention-grabbing premise it's
definitely not arthouse horror but it's
impossible to watch it to not be
entertained for a few years the Saw
franchise ran like clockwork you could
expect a new film every year each
complete with a range of intricately
designed traps and fiendish plot twists
the series definitely went downhill
after the first two movies but they
continued to entertain even as the
quality degraded the first film 2004 saw
continues to reign supreme as the
progenitor of the series and its best
outing saw was the film that got
director James Wan and writer Leigh
Whannell started as the pair wrote the
movie after meeting in film school
nowadays they're involved in everything
from the conjuring series to 2020s The
Invisible Man
it's all also made over a hundred
million dollars on a tiny budget of just
1.2 million dollars it's no wonder the
film spawned so many sequels despite
critics tepid response in case you
didn't already know saws about a serial
killer who traps his victims inside
elaborate puzzles in an effort to test
their will to live there are a few great
kills and a jaw-dropping twist in there
all brought to life by a genuinely great
cast
it's bloody disgusting and twisted and
that's just why fans love it Empire
Records is a hugely quotable
coming-of-age comedy from 1995 it's both
a throwback to similar films from the
previous decade and then attempt to be
the voice of the indie music loving
children of the 1990s teen comedies are
usually pretty hit or miss with critics
however and Empire Records missed with
most of them but as the audience score
shows it didn't miss with its target
viewers Empire Records doesn't tell a
terribly original story a group of
quirky weirdos who work in a record
store have to do everything they can to
stop a takeover from the major chain
they're all plucky underdogs they learn
about each other they posture over who
has the best music taste you know
usual it's also exactly what you'd
expect in the best possible sense and
it's pulled off thanks to a truly
spectacular cast the story goes that
Michael Nathanson president of Regency
pitchers greenlit this film the day
before he heard the pitch for clueless
he turned that movie down as he already
had a team movie in Empire Records
clueless became a massive hit and Empire
Records palmed but in the end Nathanson
ended up having created an era defining
cult classic it isn't hard to figure out
why ravenous didn't have a great
critical reception after all there is a
ton going on within this seriously
bizarre film is it a Western a horror
movie a satire it has elements of
everything and films that attempt that
sort of genre collage frequently get a
bad rap from critics but if you accept
ravenous for the whacked out horror it
is it's hard not to fall in love with
its oddball mixture of history murder
and pitch black comedy Guy Pearce leads
the cast the second lieutenant Jon
Voight an American soldier fighting in
the mexican-american war the myth though
the Windigo is blended with the story of
the Donner Party set off by a
particularly twisted interpretation of
manifest destiny it's also totally
bonkers but that's the point
ravenous is an overload of American myth
making sure there's a whole lot of
gruesome gore in there but ravenous does
nothing without reason and as a result
easily stands out as one of the
strangest and most satisfying horror
movies of the 1990s fallen is a movie
that definitely combines psychological
horror with the police procedural plots
and manages to pull off a genuinely
wonderful ending to boot and boy were
the critics unimpressed the premise of
fallen seems simple the police catch a
serial killer then have to deal with the
copycats things start to go sideways
when demonic imagery starts to appear
suggesting that there is a lot more
going on with the original killer than
what the police initially thought the
movie is anchored by an awesome cast
including Denzel Washington John Goodman
and Donald Sutherland it's a testament
to their skill that they pull fallen
story off which combines street-level
action with forces of literally biblical
proportions fallen might have seen flat
- critics but revisited today it comes
off as unique self-assured and just the
tiniest bit weird not an easy
combination but fallen pulls it off with
aplomb check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single
one
[Music]